anne marie élisabeth blaise deux soeurs
âgées de 53 et 54 ans sont les dernières
agricultrice de deux oeuvres un petit
village de 500 habitants près de
lunéville en meurthe et moselle
tous les matins depuis 40 ans
mademoiselle blaise mène ses vaches dans
un pré situé à 500 mètres de sa sphère
le soir c'est le chemin inverse des
pâturages aller table en passant par les
rues du village
mais voilà depuis 1975 les soeurs blaise
sont hors la loi elles refusent d'obéir
un arrêté municipal qui prescrit de
procéder sitôt après le passage des
bovins au nettoyage des chaussées
souillées du fait de leur digestion
en un mot les bouses de vache sont
interdites à 2,9
vous pouvez pas passer par un autre
impôt à balard on n'a rien du tout même
pas une petite ruelle pour dire qu'elle
passera une derrière l'autre il ya la
part donc on est obligé de passer par là
une fois qu'elle monte une petite grotte
alors elle éprouve le besoin de ça chez
on nous demande de balayer les routes de
tenir propre mais comment voulez vous
balayer sur 5 et 6 ans m du côté chinois
on nettoie mais plus loin que voulez
vous le village est long comme elle
estime que cet arrêté municipal
entravent leur liberté de travail les
sur blaise ont décidé de se battre
elle refuse de payer les procès verbaux
qu'on leur inflige depuis trois ans
voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui l'affairé
devant les tribunaux
monsieur le maire a refusé toute
déclaration mais nous avons pu
rencontrer le garde champêtre
si je comprends bien vous suivez les
vaches
vous suivez mademoiselle blaise et vous
vous penchez pour voir moi j'ai pas
besoin d'approcher les voies du moteur
oui pas besoin de me pencher pour les
voir et comment comment pouvez vous être
sûr qu'il s'agit des bulls des bulls de
mademoiselle blaise je vous ai dit il ya
quelques y passe dans le village est
tout passe en espagne à une chose qui
est certaine c'est qu'elle a dit fehr
entreprise je me suis trouvée quand même
avec derrière ou devant donc vous allez
pouvoir
là bas j'ai pu voir ça ne peut pas être
un chien ou ipad un gain et c'est quand
même pas la même cote encore une bonne
allumant on peut pas mettre un bouchon
c'est pas possible
vous qui êtes vétérinaire monsieur
cerise on ne pourrait-on pas imaginer
des culottes pour vaches non on a déjà
des soutiens gorge mais les culottes nom
et va chausser leurs monstres à entendre
hanche et loire j'ai eu cinq enfants
quatre garçons une fille l'amafi la
dernière à tillenay la maison curtelin
pied comme ça il ramenait toujours les
bouses de vache à la maison mal avec mes
idoles d'alors n'ont pas dans leur
demande alors à leur pied quoi y ramener
tous à la maison
oui je n'ai jamais rien dit vas y aller
je vais laver définir avec les vaches ne
nous dérange pas et les vaches les
valeurs aucune piste on la voulait tous
les jours je désagréable contre bien sur
wii et vous verrez des constats ce qu'on
pouvait
alors d'après vous ce sens votre goût
puisque les bulls dommage vous êtes
contre les bourses de valeur parce que
je la refais carreaux pu les voler ma
femme la loge il avait lui viendra qu'au
dernier après il reste encore des
bourses de l'année dernière monsieur les
bouses de vache sont contre le mur quand
drame de mai un mur vertical
oui comment les petits gabarits les
vaches pas sur la route de bagnols
qu'est ce qu'ils font mais les voitures
passent à 90 à l'heure où c'est que ça
triste c'est chez vous c'est comme de
[Rires]
nombreux à dire ça pousse de vaches de
booth
alors vous ça vous gêne pas alors ça ça
sent mauvais ça fait rien oui pour toi
c'est pas grave tu préfère habiter dans
un village
oui j'y tiens marie vialle votre voiture
tout simple on peut pas dormir dans les
vignes j'aime bien le village weir ont
travaillé les paysans c'est tout même
pas aux champs-elysées s'ils ne sont
plus maîtres dans leur village alors là
c'est la fin de la paysannerie il faut
garder les vaches lui valut à 6,11 avant
l'arrivée qu'est ce qu'il faut garder
rivage il s'est plutôt pas contre ça
cale et dans les villes ouais tu crois
que
[Musique]